talk to me today about how you see
bitcoin one of the things that i think
you've done a fantastic job talking
about is the
network itself and how to think about it
essentially defending the folks who hold
bitcoin etc and given the fact that uh
you know we could sit here and talk
probably for hours about defending space
or defending other types of attacks
you've got a very interesting
perspective so just maybe walk us
through how you see the bitcoin network
as like a defense mechanism when you say
something is a weapon system or
something is a defense system some
people like jump automatically to
thinking you're describing a gun or
something like that but
a lot of things are defense systems and
or weapon systems that you wouldn't
intuitively think about so for example
the romans created
stone roads between ports right that was
that was created by the roman legion it
was a defense system so that they could
get to you know defend their ports
easier terrestrially or for example like
this is a good example why do you think
we have gps
if i ask you that why
right yeah
we have gps to understand where we are
and where we're going right so
to have precision navigation right and
also to have precision timing because
every gps satellite has an atomic clock
in it correct so why do you think we
actually
built gps so everyone's on the same page
in terms of time
right so the reason why we built gps
like i'm in school we're getting a quiz
[Laughter]
damn f minus go ahead
when when sputnik was first launched it
was sending out a radio signal and we
had americans that were measuring that
signal
and they realized the scientists
realized that you could do time distance
of arrival off of a satellite which was
cool because then you could triangulate
your position relative to
the satellite
and so for 20 something years 25 years
the scientists kept on arguing it would
be really beneficial to humanity if we
created a giant constellation of signal
emitting satellites that would allow
anyone any anywhere in the world to be
able to triangulate their position
relative to those satellites it would be
awesome for navigation
and by the way the way to do it
precisely is if we put super precise
clocks into space which would double
benefit us because then everyone would
have basically free access to precision
timing as well
and so the scientists argued for decades
that this would be valuable to humanity
but that's not why
it was funded because it seemed it
seemed too expensive at the time it
didn't people didn't fully understand
its value
until we ran into an issue
where we were in a cold war with the
with the ussr
and we had the capability to launch
intercontinental ballistic missiles and
they those intercontinental ballistic
missiles knew where they were because
they had inertial navigation systems in
them that were accurate for something
like 30 minutes ditto for if we
scrambled bombers and we wanted to fly
bombers and drop bombs they would have
inertial navigation systems inside of
them that were accurate enough
but a problem came up
where what if russia shot first or what
if the ussr shot first
and they targeted our bombers and they
targeted our icbm silos we would have to
be able to
mutually assure the destruction of
moscow
if that happened right we'd have to make
it too expensive for them to make that
decision
and so the way we do that is we have
something called trident missiles or
submarine launch ballistic missiles we
basically park nuclear missiles
hidden under the water all around the
world so that if anyone tried to shoot
first
it would hurt them
right we would we could guarantee that
that would hurt them even if we lost our
icbms even if we lost our bombers so
it's called the nuclear triad there's a
problem though technical problem the
technical problem is that submarine has
been under water for 30 days and the
inertial navigation system on it
is useless
so if we did get shot first
and then we just decided to do a second
strike to mutually assure the
destruction of moscow and we launched
that trident missile and it breaks the
surface how is it going to know where it
is
it has no idea where it is correct
missile has no idea
and so
what we realized is
man we need a giant constellation of
satellites so that anything anywhere in
the world at any time could know where
it is particularly a trident submarine
large ballistic missile
and so that's eventually what caused us
to fund gps and then once we funded gps
and once we built this massive weapon
system right that was intended
explicitly to mutually assure the
destruction
of ussr
did we realize wow there's a lot of
other stuff that you could do with gps
this is great for civilization just like
the scientists kept on saying and then
in desert storm
the value of precision timing and
navigation was very clear and since then
especially once we turned off selective
availability and allowed everyone to
have precision navigation and timing
it's clear
but people often forget that gps is a
weapon system
it exists to mutually assure the
destruction of other countries right
there's a lot of weapons systems like we
have
that we have that do the same thing
right nuclear
hardened satellite communications right
pcpip the internet right the internet
exists so that we can survive we can
have c2 that survives a nuclear level
strike
shah right
as in shaw 256
right as in designed by the nsa
these are these are these are systems
that are explicitly intended for the
defense
of the united states and so
um you know if we keep pulling that
thread eventually we get to
all of the critical enabling
technologies that go into bitcoin we get
tcp we get sha we get precision timing
and synchronization of nodes through gps
we get it written in c plus plus which
was you know something that an american
designed at bell laboratories
every single piece of bitcoin that
fundamentally matters is effectively
a piece of technology that was designed
to improve military scale defense
particularly against
the destruction of nukes
and so
if you continue to pull that thread a
little bit further and a little bit
further
you can start to conceptualize
bitcoin as way more than just
money
bitcoin is and i know a lot of people on
twitter will be angry at me for saying
this bitcoin is a weapon system
just like gps is a weapon system
it is a weapon system designed
explicitly for self-defense
and it is extremely effective right it
it it is literally
nuclear resistant like every piece of it
was designed explicitly to be resistant
to nuclear strikes
so um that's
you know that's pretty interesting right
there's some pro there's probably some
national strategic
opportunities with bitcoin that we could
take advantage of and that's kind of
what i want to explore